قال الرئيس الامريكي في قمه الجماعات
للمره الاولى منذ وصوله الى البيت الابيض
بناظير الصيني
انه لا بديل للمحادثات المباشره بين
واشنطن وبيجين وشهدت القمه تجديد الجاربين
على الرجاء ان تفضي القمه الى تخفيف
التوتر المتساعد واداره التنفس بينهما بما
يمكن من معالجه الخلافات الثنائيه وبلفات
ذات اهتمام دوري
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مصارعه
ما هي نتائج اول قمه بين الرئيسين
الامريكي والصيني و الافضل الى تخفيف
التوتر الذي شهدته العلاقات بين البلدين
في بحر جنوب الصين وبضيق تايوان وكذلك ملف
كوريا الشماليه ثم الى اي مدى تعكس
تصريحات جون كيربي منسقه لاتصالات في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي دعم واشنطن الصين
الموحده وعدم دعم استقلال تايوان شكلت
اجواء الايجابيه لللقاء بين الزعيميين ثم
نبحث في مدى تاثير اي تقارب او خلاف صيني
امريكي على مسار الصراع بين الغربي وروسيا
لا سيما الحرب في اوكرانيا وعلى الامن
الغذائي والطاقه في العالم وقضايا منطقه
الشرق الاوسط والملتقى
[موسيقى]
وسط تصاعد للتنافس بين البلدين وفي ظل
تحركات العسكريه من هنا وهناك فقمه التوتر
بينهما التقى الرئيسان الامريكي جو فايدن
والصين في قمه ثنائيه على هامشي قمه
العشرين في بالي اندونيسيا قمه شهدت القاء
قليل من الورود وكثيرا من خطاب حسني
النوايا الذي ركز على المصلحه المشتركه في
خفض التوترات من خلال اداره التنفس
والقيام بدور مهم في معالجه ملفات دوليه
تقلق استقرار عالم اليوم امنيا ومعيشيا
بعيدا الذي قال ان بلاده عاده لقياده
العالم اكد خلال لقائه الرئيس الصيني ان
الطرفين سيسعيان لاداره التنافسي بينهما
الجيش
واجرينا حديثا حول نوايانا واولوياتنا
واتفقنا على الدفاع عن المصالح والقيم
الامريكيه وتعزيز قيم الانسانيه والوقوف
الى جانب النظام العالمي سوف نتنافس بشده
وسوف ندير التنافس بمسؤوليه وندعو الدول
للالتزام بالقواعد العالميه كما ناقشنا
سياسه الصين الواحده وانها لم تتغير اتفقت
معك على الحفاظ على الامن والاستقرار في
مضيق تايوان وسنعمل سويا على التصدي
للتحديات العالميه
وبشعليه التوتر بين الصين وتايوان قال
بيدر انه لن تكون هناك محاوله لاجتياح
تايوان مشددا على ضروره حل الخلافات سلميه
[موسيقى]
في حرب بارده تحدثت مع تشيع عده مرات وكنا
واضحين ولا اعتقد انه ستكون هناك محاوله
اجتياح تايوان في الوقت القريب العلاقه
بين الصين الاعتزال كما هي ويجب حل
الخلافات بالطرق السلميه
اوه
الرئيس الصيني قال من ناحيته انه يريد
محادثات صريحه مع بيض بشان القضايا
الاستراتيجيه في العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه والمسائل الاقليميه والدوليه
50 عاما مرت منذ بدايه العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين الصين والولايات المتحده
شهيدنا خلالها احداثا كثيره واكتسبنا
التجربه والخبرات وتعلمنا الدروس التاريخ
هو افضل كتاب نتعلم منه وعلينا ان ننظر
للتاريخ كي نرسم المستقبل
كرئيسين لدولتين عظيمتين علينا رسم المسار
الصحيح للعلاقات الثنائيه وتعزيز هذه
العلاقه اي رجل دوله يجب ان يعرف كيف يقود
بلده وكيف يتوافق مع الدول الاخرى والعالم
يتوقع العالم من الصين وامريكا ان تتعامل
بطريقه مناسبه وقد حظي اجتماعنا باهتمام
العالم في اجتماعنا اليوم انا جاهز ليكون
لدينا تبادل اراء صريح في ما يخص المسائل
المهمه استراتيجيا في العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه والمسائل الاقليميه والعالميه
لن يعيد العلاقات الى مسارها الصحيح من
اجل خدمه البلدين على
في حديث التفاصيل قال البيت الابيض ان
بعيدا ابلغ نظيره واصلي شيء جيمبين ان
التنافس بين البلدين يجب الا يتحول ابدا
الى صراع واضاف البيت الابيض ان بعد ابلغ
شيء بضروره اداره واشنطن وبيجين المنافسه
بينهما والحفاظ على قنوات للاتصال واشار
البيت الابيض الى ان بيض وشي ناقش بشكل
صريح اولويات البلدين وعددا من القضايا
وبشان حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قال البيت
الابيض ان بيدل وعشي اتفق على معارضه
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه في اوكرانيا
وعلى الجانب الاخر افادت وسائل اعلام
صينيه ان الرئيس سير جيمنج شدد على ان
تايوان ستبقى الخط الاحمر الاول في
العلاقه مع واشنطن وضحا ان اي جهه تسعى
لفصل تايوان عن الصين تنتهي كل المصالح
الاساسيه لامتهم وقال الرئيس الصيني انه
يامل ان يقرنا الجانب الامريكي اقواله
بالافعال وان يلتزم بسياسه الصين الواحده
وفقا لوسائل اعلام صينيه
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من بيجين
الاعلامي والبحث السياسي وامل
المستشار السابق في مجلس الامن القومي
اسالك عن
تقييمك لهذه اللقاء لهذه القمه الاولى بين
الرئيسين منذ ان دخل الرئيس الى البيت
الابيض كيف وجدت هذا اللقاء في هذا
التوقيت
مرحبا بكم اهلا وسهلا
الاجتماع حوار بناء وصريح ويعني وفي على
مستوى يعني اعلى من دولتين
فهذا يساهم في ازاله سوء تفاهم وكذلك
زياده التفاهم وتبادل بين البلدين ومن جنب
الصين فقد يعني تواجه حسين
بشكل اكثر وضوح يعني همم في كثير من
القضايا واعتقد هذا اللقاء يعني هو همم
يعني يساهم في عوده في عدد العلاقات
الثانيه الامريكيه الى مسار التطور السليم
والمستقر وكذلك ايضا
اي اشاره ايجابيه
للوضع الدولي والتطور يعني
انتعاش الاقتصادي العالميه ف التعاون بين
الصين والولايات المتحده
الشعبين بلدين وكذلك العالم كله كيف يمكن
قياس بان هذا اللقاء كما قلت كان بناءا
ايي نعم طبعا يمكن ان نرى من خلال
البيانات
مضمون الاجتماع
فهناك همم يعني همم
الاجواء كان همم
كذلك ايجابيا وهناك همم
وتعهدت همم
ايضا بعد عدم همم
تشكيل تحالفات همم العسكريه او اقليميه
اللي همم
اتفق كذلك همم الرئيسان بلدين على الايجاد
همم والنقاط المشتركه رغم وجود الخلافات
واداره الخلافات بشكل منافق وكل هذه همم
يعني هي صار ايجابيه لتطور العلاقات
السينما الامريكيه
باعتقادك ما اهم تحقق في هذا اللقاء وقد
يشكل ارضيه ايجابيه
واقول انه هذا اللقاء كان من اهم اللقاءات
في 75 عاما بين زع- زعيمين من زعماء
العالم هما في قمه
اقوى دولتين في العالم ولم تكن العلاقات
بينهما طيبه رغم ان الرئيس
اكثر من خمس مكالمات هاتفيا لكن كان هذا
هو اللقاء المباشر الاول وهمم
[موسيقى]
وتيره اللقاء وايضا نظره الكلام كانت
ايجابيه وفيما تتعلق تايوان تحديدا انا
اتفقوا مع زميلي الصيني فان نبره اللقاء
كانت واضحه الرئيس
مكرر مجددا على ان السياسه واشنطن في
الصين واحده لم تتغير ولن يكون هناك اي
توجه لدعم استقلال للتايوان طبعا هذا
موجود من قبل لكن كان مهما ان يعادل تاكيد
عليه في هذا اللقاء وهي نقطه وخطوه اولى
مهمه وما لا يقل اهميه ان يتبع هذا اللقاء
لقاءات وسوف يذهب وزير الخارجيه بلانكن
والى الصين
ونعملوا اننا سنرى مجموعه من اعاده
تفعيل اللقاءات والعلاقات بشكل اكثر
ايجابي معك
الموقف الصيني واضح والبيان الصيني واضح
على واشنطن ان تقرانا الاقوال بالافعال
هناك عدم ثقه من قبل الجانب الصيني
وبالتالي في اطار مفهوم اداره التنافس كما
اتفق عليه الطرفان كيف يمكن ان يشكل هذا
اللقاء قاعده ايجابيه في ظل عدم وجود
الثقه
ما اعداء اروح الحوار بين واشنطن والصين
فيما يتعلق بقضيه تايوان وعلى كلا الطرفين
ان يتراجعا من الجانب العسكري في المواجهه
بينهما
الصينيون كانوا يجرون الكثيره من
المناورات التدريبات العسكريه وخاصه في
البحر التي بدات تهدد تايوان المتحده ايضا
كانت تزود تايوان باسلحه حديثه تضع
الدفاعي هجومي والتراجع عن هذه المواجهه
العسكريه مهم واعاده تاسيس روح التفاهم
الدبلوماسي مهم للغايه
المتحده
بان قضيه تايوان يجب حله السلبيه والصين
ايضا ملتزمه بالحل السلمي لكن نظامي
البلدين الصيني وفي نظام تايوان مختلفانه
كثيرا ولهذا السبب هناك جهد ينبغي ان يبذل
لجعل العلاقات اكثر توافقا ولي اعاده
الامور الى مسار اكثر طبيعيه
الحمراء الاساسيه في هذه المقربه
الامريكيه الصينيه وهنا اسال ضيفي من
بيجين السيد هو همم الرئيس الامريكي قال
فيما يشبه الضمانات من قبل الجانب الصيني
بانه لن يكون هناك اجتياح
لطايوان في
مقابلته واشنطن وقالت بانها ملتزمه بسياسه
الصين الواحده هل نتكلم عن ضمانات من
الطرفين
اعتقد يعني من
بالصيني
[موسيقى]
الجذور السبب التوتر
مجموعه صغيره
[موسيقى]
يعني ازاله الجميع وعوامل الصينيه في
الجزيره هذا كله
يعني عوامل او اسباب تدفع اللي توتر في
هذه المنطقه همم
يحاول ان نقرا المشهد المشهد هل ترجح ان
الجانب الصيني قد قدم للجانب الامريكي
ضمانات ما يتعلق باجتياح تايوان
اعتقد هذا يعني هناك شروط فاذا كان يعني
حدثت اكدت الصين مرارا تكرارا اذا كان
هناك مبدا واحد وهناك التزام جيد اثار
تكون همم
بحاله استقرار وسلام واذا كان اي انتحاك
لهذا المبدا وانتحاق للسياده الصين فهناك
همم التساعد وتواتر العسكري فهذا موضوع
همم يعني مواقف همم
قرارتها السينما تكرارا الوضع يعني توتر
تتوقف على
السلوك المجمع صغير من الانفصاليين وكذلك
قوه دعما لها من الخارج
طيب بالعوده الى هذه الكلمه المفتاحيه في
فهم العلاقه بين واشنطن والصين تحديدا
فيما يتعلق بملف تايوان والصين الواحده
منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي جون كيربي قال للجزيره ان
هناك اوجه في العلاقات تتنافس فيها واشنطن
معاصيل واوجه اخرى يسودها التوتر مؤكدا
على سياسه واشنطن بشان الصين الموحده
الدقيق الشركه التي تتموه نحن لا نسعى
للصراع مع الصين لذلك لا يوجد سبب
وهذا هو موقف الولايات المتحده منذ عقود
عديده
ضيف يا سيد جوردن ادرس ايضا من الملفات
الساخنه في هذا اللقاء ما يتعلق بكوريا
الشماليه هناك تاكيد من قبل واشنطن وايضا
الامريكيه بان الرئيس الامريكي طرح على
الجانب الصيني التحرك او الضغط على بيوجع
فيما يتعلق باجراء بتجارب نوويه في مقابل
تلقي واشنطن بمزيد من جنودها وحضورها
العسكري في المنطقه الى اي مدى هذا اللقاء
يشكل ربما فرصه جيده في هذا الملف ما
يتعلق بكوريا الشمالي
من الواقعه تماما بعد تايوان العلاقات مع
كوريا الشماليه هي واحده من اهم القضايا
التي كانت الولايات المتحده والصين بحاجه
الى بحثها وهذا امر ليس جديد الوقت
المتحده
من الزمان لحمل الصيد على ممارسه الضغوط
على كوريا الشماليه للتخفيف من حده التوتر
الشماليه ستستجيب لكن واضح ان هناك تصعيد
عسكري بين الشطري شبه الجزيره الكوريه من
جهه
الشماليه واليابان بسبب التجارب السابقيه
ولان الناس المتحده ايضا عاده الكثير
التدريبات العسكريه بين بينها وبينها
البلدان المعنيه والتي توقفت فتره من
الزمن لهذا هناك قدر لا يستهانوا به من
التوتر ويامل الامريكيون ان الصين ستمارس
ضغوطها لكن ليس واضحا هل ان الكوريين
الشماليين سيقللون من تدريباتهم
وممارساتهم الاخرى قد يكون هناك تطور وهذا
واضح في الحوار الصيني الامريكي لكن ليس
واضحا هل هل الامر ينعكس
ايجابيا على قضيه العلاقه ما كوريا
الشماليه لا لكن الوزير
يتابع هذا الموضوع في زيارته المقبله الى
الصين
بهذا الملف ملف كوريا الشماليه هل من
الوارد ان تضغط همم لان واشنطن تقول اذا
وصلت فيونديال برامجها العسكريه هذا معنا
حضور اكثر حضور عسكري اكثر اكثر لواشنطه
في المنطقه
في اعتقاد الصين انه لا يجب ان يكون هناك
التجارب والصاروخيه وتم العقوبات ثم
التواجد العسكري هذا الدائره ليست دائره
صحيحه فيجب السن ستقدم يعني
مناسب
لاجراء والمفاوضات
محادثات السداسيه فالسين ترى ان
يجب مراعاه كل الاهتمامات لجميع اعتراف
مثلا
لاهتمام الاحتمامات الامنيه لكوريا
الشماليه
وكمانها وكذلك اعاده اخلاء الشبه الجزيره
من الاسلحه النوويه فيجب ان يكون هناك
مسار تقدم معا او يعني كنا قد تنازلات
بالليل كيف يصل الى النقود فقط
نصف دقيقه لاسالك عن الجانب حديث في هذا
المفهوم اداره التنافس من واشنطن وضمان
استقرار للاسواق العالميه ماذا عن هذا
الشق في نصف دقيقه لو تكرمت
تمام الصين يعني تدعم التسهيل الاجراءات
التجاره الحره
وتعرض فرض او اضافه حواجز سياسيه
للتبادلات التجاريه والتكنولوجيه
والاقتصاديه طيب
ما يتعلق بنفس الملف واشنطن في عهد اداره
الرئيس الفرضت الكثير من العقوبات
الاقتصاديه على بيجين ماذا عن هذا اللقاء
وتاثيره على عندما نتكلم على اكبر
اقتصادين في العالم عن اقتصاد العالميه
بصفه عامه
اه يا مناره
في نظام العقوبات الامريكيه على الصين
حاليا والسبب هو ان
اهميه هذا العقوبات على الصعيد الداخلي
فالدار الامريكي
المنتجات الامريكيه على التكنولوجيا
الصناعه الصينيه بصراحه لا اتوقع
من ولايه يوروغون جوردن ادمز المستشاره
السابق في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
شكرا لك وكذلك ضيفي من بيجين رنجوان
الاعلامي والباحث السياسي
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج اوراق
الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]